hallo leute ich es wieder mal waren und
willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt und heute machen wir nichts aus
einem film oder einer serie
denn heute machen wir ein lieber weiter
dass daraus für die hintergrundgeräusche
das ist super danke ich hoffe man hört
mich und wenn ja dann entschuldige ich
mich jetzt schon für alle das ist nicht
ganz meine karriere die ich machen
könnte geräusche nachmachen ratet das
geräusch das war ein delfin bitteschön
ich lasse es glaube ich doch mit der
karriere als geräusche nach macher ist
es überhaupt ein beruf ja also wir sind
fast eine minute im video und es geht
noch nicht mal um das video
wir machen heute dieses image also
dieses stück kuchen ich hatte nämlich
vor einigen monaten schon die idee das x
1 m nachkommen möchte und heute ist
endlich der tag der tage gekommen ich
hab gesagt vanessa heute machst du es
viele mode ist deuten darauf hin dass
sie aus dem japanischen asiatischen
bereich kommen und deshalb glaube ich
auch so diese art von kuchen in animes
oft gesehen zu haben
auf jeden fall indes lauter ist nämlich
l immer so einen weißen so eine weiße
torte mit erdbeeren drauf oder mit einer
ehren wäre ich bin nicht ganz sicher ist
ganz viel süßes aber ich glaube diesen
weißen gucken oft gesehen zu haben und
das bringt mich zur erkenntnis dass ich
glaube dass die japaner einfach auch so
weise kuchen stehen ich könnte mich
jetzt natürlich auch irren aber irren
ist menschen was wir auf jeden fall für
dieses stück torte brauchen ist ein
luftiger biskuitteig und dann natürlich
ganz wichtig eine weise buttercreme und
eine erdbeere unseren bizkit boden
brauchen wir 190 gramm mehl 100 gramm
speisestärke zehn gramm backpulver sechs
eier ein bisschen 3 1 225 gramm zucker
einen teelöffel wandel extra und drei
esslöffel zwazl und jetzt lasst uns den
kuchen backen
oh gott ich habe euch ganz vergessen zu
sagen ich habe
die habe ich mir aber nicht gekauft die
habe ich von meiner mama bekommen das
ist nämlich eine kitchenette und sie
rührte er alles was du willst
wirklich alles
und du musst an den strom und velemir
kommt jetzt jemand mit der thermomix ob
sie besser
der thermomix kostet aber auch eine
million euro wir packen das mehl in die
schüssel jetzt kommen unsere
speisestärke 100 gramm speisen der und
jetzt kommt noch 10.000 mark webber
hinzu und das vorführen wir kurz
miteinander jetzt wird toll denn jetzt
benutzen wir unsere neue küchenmaschine
küchenmaschinen pop ich werde nicht in
monetarisiert hier an dieser stelle
eigentlich sollte man nehme ich habe sei
aber wie lifte bereits seit of life
jetzt müssen wir sechs eier trennen und
das eiweiß in unsere schüssel machen
ich kann dinge können euch an der stelle
mal überlegen welches fujimori ich als
nächstes mal machen soll bestimmt habt
ihr alle 1 was ihr unbedingt mal in real
live sehen möchte und das kommt jetzt in
den becken noch eine prise salz rein und
wir starten
ich liebe neue maschinen
in meinen drei viertel von dem zucker
während des drehs rieseln lassen
[Applaus]
so isch clip den als schaum jetzt mal
rüber ok ich weiß warum es handys torten
welt immer mit dieser maschine kommt das
gut an
jetzt kommen unsere eigelbe nicht
schlüssel und es kommen die 50 gramm
zucker reihen der woche und ein
teelöffel war 0 extrakt darf natürlich
auch nicht fehlen ich hab hier so'n ich
mag am liebsten dieses vanille extrakt
von dort doktor med care vollgas ich
habe das heiße wasser vergessen
richtig krass aufgeschlagen ist ich bin
glücklich mit bisschen faszinieren danke
mama für dieses geschenk jetzt müssen
wir uns in dieses algebra es fast so als
ob es zum ersten mal
ich wollte mal ein bisschen was rein so
jetzt alles miteinander verrühren und
jetzt kommen natürlich unsere mischung
dazu und für den dann so rein
[Musik]
das muss jetzt eine springform ich habe
diesen trick schon verraten aber die
kennen mich dass unser teilnehmen war
kaffee draufpacken analyse school
wir machen noch ein kleines bisschen
peter brand der moment ist gekommen und
datei kommt jetzt in die dieses schöne
dinge kommt jetzt für eine halbe stunde
bei 175 grad in den backofen man sollte
ihn vor während ober und unterhitze für
euch geht das natürlich alles viel
schneller ich habe biscuit boden gemacht
der muss jetzt natürlich erstmal
abkühlen aber in der zeit wären wir
nicht verletzen sondern die buttercreme
machen
buttercreme ist zum glück leichter zu
machen und für sie brauchen wir 500
gramm butter 750 gramm puderzucker
30 milliliter milch und misst gerade
aufgefallen dass der biscuit boden noch
nicht fertig ist ich kotze scheiße ist
etwas aufgefallen ich hasse machen ist
etwas aufgefallen was nicht so schlimm
ist aber doch schon blöd für das video
ich muss nämlich gelbe lebensmittelfarbe
in diesem scheiss biskuitteig machen
weil dieses im vollen den gelben teig
hat man das natürlich nicht so
hinbekommt nur wie man eier und so
benutzt deswegen mache ich jetzt den
biskuit teig noch mal der andere ist ja
auch noch hohe gewesen und so wir sehen
uns dann gleich und machen dann die
buttercreme und alles andere leute nicht
verzagen
vanessa fragen ich hab die kippels kids
und sie blasen
okay leute hallo es ist zwei stunden
vergangen ich habe einen zweiten
diskothek gemacht dennoch nicht ganz
abgekühlt ist der hoffentlich jetzt die
richtige farbe hat weil ich
lebensmittelfarbe reingemacht habe also
jetzt wieder überhaupt nicht schön gelb
aus und damit würde ich sagen machen wir
uns jetzt an die buttercreme die butter
kommt jetzt in unsere ruhe schüsse ich
mache die doppelte portion ich schreibe
euch das rezept einfach unten rein und
mache die doppelte ein kilo butter und
jetzt müssen wir die butter so richtig
schön schaumig schlagen das könnt ihr
natürlich mit einem handgerät machen
oder mit dem mixer fünfte auf der macht
das schon
sehr gefragt waren nicht wirklich gut
aufgeschlagen
in unserem kilo butter muss jetzt 750
gramm puderzucker rein gesiebt werden
jetzt auf niedrigster stufe zeug
einrühren dass ihr 750 gramm da rein
gemacht habe und jetzt kommt die sahne
also wenn das nicht mal den buttercreme
ist dann weiß ich auch nicht weiter für
unser nächsten schritt brauchen wir
[Musik]
wir müssen jetzt irgendwie schneiden
schneiden wir hier oben einfach so
diese werbung aus ich habe vorhin mit
kelly geschrieben oder uns ist
aufgefallen dass früher
es gab schon immer im modus könnt ihr
noch als man so damals so sternchen
grinst sternchen geschrieben hat das war
dies nur alt geworden
wissen sie doch nicht bei gelb jetzt in
zwei teile auf stecken wir müssen exakt
gleich groß sein
der ist orten welt vanessas torten welt
da muss jetzt eine menge buttercreme auf
ungefähr so viel dass es dann so oben
drauflegt klingen jetzt anders und tief
durchatmen
gute portion von unser krems in unseren
spritzbeutel ich alles machen wir die
zwischenschicht zwischen beiden
[Musik]
okay ein halbes kilo
jetzt kommt der deckel obendrauf
jesus maria und josef
jetzt müssen wir natürlich den sand
erstmal mit einer fetten butter schicht
machen
mai live search please kill me now it's
so much jetzt schwierig das einfach mal
rein und schon haben wir eine leckere
kommen ragen wie viel von den rest hat
schon hier oben drauf
[Musik]
halleluja sie hat es endlich geschafft
sie haben einen tag arbeit steckt
dahinter und solisten welt so schön
natürlich müssen jetzt noch die
wunderschönen erdbeeren drauf und ich
habe ganz tolle schöne eltern gefunden
dafür lege ich jetzt einfach so durch
dass die bildschöne aus the pressure das
kann ich nicht
der wirbel
ihr könnt die anspannung förmlich
riechen sie dich nach erdberg wenig habe
die im body torte gebacken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die sind
und jetzt meine damen und herren stellen
uns natürlich wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt der
kuchen aus whatsapp gehabt wenn ihr den
auch machen wollt nimmt auf jeden fall
eine leichtere creme als buttercreme
buttercreme hat es gut gepasst damit
dass alles so steif und gut aussieht
perfekt dafür aber für den geschmack ist
schon sehr süß macht es nicht nach aber
es zum bäcker und dieser biscuit boden
das lustigste was ich jemals in meinem
leben gegessen habe der geht direkt hier
auf wetter doch irgendwas machen keine
sorge ich denke dass aus
[Musik]
tja leute wenn euch das video gefallen
hat nicht vergessen einen daumen nach
oben geben oder fängt nettes kommentar
schreiben oder ihr schreibt was jetzt
nächstes nachkochen soll ein neues image
oder doch etwas aus dem film oder eine
serie ich freue mich hier sind noch zwei
weitere videos die könnt ihr euch
anschauen abonnieren nicht vergessen
wenn sie kein neues video verpassen
wollt abonnieren und die glocke und
alles andere was man so machen kann und
muti wie geht sich jetzt den traurigen
liebesfilm angucken mit menschen die
niemals zusammen kommen werden und dabei
ist sie ein kuchen der aussieht wie eine
mutti